فايز الدويري الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجي لواء فايزه دويري مرحبا بك
معنا اذا كيف ترصد التقدم حول باخموت
ووجهه النظر الامريكيه حول بقاله هذا
الانجاز
الان الحديث عن معركه باخم يعيدنا لقراءه
معارك سابقه
جميع هذه المعارك اخذت وقت لكن اخذت وقت
اكثر
بسبب مجموعه من العوامل
النفاقموت تمثل البوابه الجنوبيه اذا ما
تم السيطره عليها بصوره كامله ستنفتح
الطرق الى الشمال الغربي
سلافيانسك
وقد تفتح الطريق ام زيرو 3 باتجاه الشمال
الشرقي
الى منها
وبالتالي سقوطها سيكون له تداعيات وقد
يعني لا اتفق بالمطلق عندما قال لن يكون
هناك انجازا كبيرا لماذا لانه يعتمد على
الخطوه التاليه
هناك فرق بين ان يتم سقوط هذه المدينه
عنوه وبالقوه وبعد معركه حاسمه او ان
تنسحب منها القوات لبناء خط دفاعي جديد
القوات الاوكرانيه تقاتل حتى الرمق الاخير
اذا عندما يتم السيطره عليها تكون الخسائر
لطرفي الصراع كبيره جدا ويصعب تعويضها لكن
تبقى القوات المهاجمه
الذيل الاداري لها اكبر واقوى وبالتالي قد
تستغل النجاحات وتفرض نجاحات اضافيه
ما هي نقاط الضعف لطرف الروسي ونقاط الضعف
في الطرف الاوكراني في معركه بخموت
الان نقاط الضعف الرئيسيه للجانب الروسي
تتمثل
بازدواجيه القوات
والتنسيق يبدو بين هذه القوات ليس مثاليا
قوات جاءت من سوليدار اتجهت غربا ثم اتجهت
جنوبا سيطرت على البلده
الاطراف الشماليه من
من باخموت وتحاول ان تسيطر ولو بالنيران
على طرق الامداد فيما من الشرق ومن الجنوب
الجيش الروسي يعتمد مقاربه مختلفه يعتمد
الموجات البشريه والهجمات الملاحق
المتلاحقه وحتى الان تتكسر نقطه الضعف
بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني بدا هناك اربع
طرق امداد وتستخدم من اجل عمليات التزويد
تم قطع منها وبقيت طريقه واحده التي تذهب
باتجاه سلافيا نصف اذا ما قطعت لتصبح الان
فخمه مطوقه والقوات المحاصره عاجلا ام
اجلا ستخسر المعركه اذا لم ياتيها الامداد
بالذخائر وكافه المتطلبات وانقاذها بقوات
تكسر الطوق وتعيد التواصل اذا نقاط القوه
للجانب الروسي
الهجوم من ثلاث اتجاهات نقاط القوه
للجانب الاوكراني الابقاء وهو ضعيف جدا
على طريق واحد ونقاط الضعف كما اشرت لها
طيب لواء فايز فيما يقرا
غربيا عن حدود التسليح
لاوكرانيا برايك هذه المحددات التي رسمت
في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
اليوم الى اي درجه ستنعكس على الواقع
النفسي الحرب النفسيه للطرف الاوكراني
يعني هي الان الجانب الاوكراني سقف
المطالب عالي جدا وهذا الطلب ليس ليس
جديدا وليس ابن اللحظه منذ اشهر والرئيس
يطالب بالطائرات وطائرات اف 16 تحديدا
لانها طائرات
للقتال الجوي اكثر منه للقصف الارضي ولكن
عفوا القسم الارضي اكثر منه للقتال الجوي
ولكن اعتقد انها ضمن الخطوط الحمراء حتى
التصريحات من قبل نفس الدوله نجدها تختلف
ما بين يوم واخر بالامس كان هناك اشاره من
بعض المواقع ان امريكا تسمح للدول التي
تمتلك طائرات اف 16 ان ترسلها
وقصدت بذلك بولندا في هذا اليوم هناك نوع
من التراجع الجانب الفرنسي وعد سابقا بانه
قد يدرس الموضوع الان هو تراجع عنه حتى
بولندا التي طلبت السماح من امريكا بان
ترسل هذه الطائرات عادت وقالت يجب العمل
ضمن اطار مجموعه متكامله دعيني اقول
الطائرات ثابته الجماع الطائرات المقاتله
لا تزال بعيده المنال وان بدات تدريب
الطيارين يحتاج الى فتره طويله في بعض
الحالات اكثر من عام شكرا لك لواء فايزه
دويري الخبيره العسكري والاستراتيجي احدث
عمان شكرا لك